because you've been tracking
crowdfunding for so long because you've
supported so many other campaigns you
know so you've seen how other people
have done it in your observation and
experience now that you're in the midst
of your own campaign is crowdfunding
getting more difficult I think it's I
think it's possible to raise more money
more easily um if you're able to execute
correctly um I don't think you can just
throw something up anymore and expect it
to get funded at any level I think there
are more and more I think the challenge
is that there's a lot there's a lot more
really good projects out going on at the
same time before it used to be like oh
here's this really cool one and then a
couple months later oh here's another
cold one now there's like five amazing
ones happening at the same time and you
know it's gettin it's gettin very
crowded with that so you have to you
have to be really creative and you have
to you know have something that people
want to want to be a part of but I think
I think in some ways it's kind of it's
grown proportionally you know where he
said yeah it's getting crowded but that
also means more people aren't looking at
it there's a lot more people like you
know a year or two ago you would mention
Kickstarter to somebody who you know
wasn't in the film industry or anything
and they're like I know that is and then
you'd have to explain it to them and now
I find myself talking to people and they
know exactly what that is or at least
they've heard something about and maybe
they haven't checked it out but they
kind of have an idea of what it is so
there are more people looking at it and
you see a lot more big projects now to
like you know two million dollar
projects or things that are making like
a lot and and they're actually doing it
whereas a year ago somebody raising
50,000 zero that's that's an
insurmountable amount but now you do see
it happening so I think I think God has
gotten more crowded for sure but there
are also just more people out there
looking at it and willing to contribute
so I think you know it's just as
difficult regardless of how much you're
raising it yeah and it's just having
that pine and reaching those people yeah
I think it's always been something that
because now you you really have to you
really have to be able to execute a
great great game plan and how about
bring a lot of creativity to it to be
successful so now that you're doing this
now that you've taken the plunge what
are you learning about crowdfunding and
beyond them what are you learning about
shoots will you learn about general
product bye-bye it by taking the plunge
and diving into the crowdfunding
landscape I think well we learn to to
narrow down our message for sure and you
know we learned that we learned that you
can't do you can't do post and
crowdfunding at the same time we
definitely learned that lesson because
we wanted to get our two new episodes
out um you know as an aspect as a
selling point darling campaign and we're
only we're going to make one of those
and you know that's a lot of effort to
get that one released let alone two to
one and two weeks early it definitely
has you know been been difficult obvi
seem like you said you know narrowing
down our message and then you know do
the post and I think we we knew that
going in you know like okay we should
have every single thing ready and so but
you know we had a plan also so we
thought okay well this is the schedule
for how we're going to keep that even
though you know ideally yeah you would
but I mean the reality of something
being ideal is that it's an ideal and
you can't always do that i mean we could
spend the next six months the next year
planning for it and then and then still
have like an end result that doesn't
work so I mean is it worth that time or
do you just take that that jump and do
it and you know there's like the quote
by Ray Bradbury that I like a lot or you
know don't you know jump off the cliff
and build your wings on the way down and
I think with something like this I mean
you you have to you kind of just have to
jump in and like okay so you fail you
fail you move on and you learn like
that's
that you can do you can't just you can't
just sit there and you know bemoaned on
it you have to you have to move on and
you know I think back to the previous
question where you know is it becoming
harder or easier I think maybe there are
people who are doing it a second time
they're going for it again after having
failed or they're going for it with a
different project and you know whether
they were successful or or fail the
first time and and I think that's
something that has become more
acceptable recently where it's not a
one-shot deal anymore I think I think
one thing that that I've learned is is
is that momentum aspect um Mikey you
know the moment the moment you can't
take a break the moment you stop is the
moment your campaign goes back to like a
noise level of 0 and if you want it to
hit that way you've got to get to that
one hundred and you only get that by
continuing to push them the moment you
stop you your momentum goes to zero um
outside to do not own use and and one of
the things that we can't kind of had
agreed to from the very beginning was
like like we weren't going to cancel the
campaign no matter what like we were
going to see it out through the end and
and take it for what it was you know
like win or lose because this is an
experience that you haven't and we've
seen people cancel them before and we
just knew that that wasn't that wasn't
our path like like you fail what you
feel or eastleigh if you're gonna fail
you know you go out fighting and and
that's what we're doing so now you know
where where you know where six days away
and still have very high mountain to
climb but I mean we're climbing it and
you know we'll see what's on the other
end of it but you know that I don't I
don't I don't see any value in giving up
like you don't we don't learn from that
you don't get that full experience of
like what did we do wrong if half way
through your like this isn't working
like yeah Oh keep pushing yeah that's
what I was going to touch on next you
know for that I find it very admirable
that because generally especially with
Kickstarter you know once if you're
coming down to your final week and if
you're not over that twenty percent
threshold and I'm
using that because you guys are you guys
are above ten percent I think it's less
than 20 percentage I'm kind of in that
range no but generally people have long
given up in you too or I decided you
know what we're not going to do what
we're going to push this all the way
through and I think there's there's so
many lessons that continued you can
continue to be gained and learn from in
this final week tell us about the spirit
of not giving up and then seeing this
through win and why that decision is so
important to you guys yeah i think when
we went into it um we we when you we
were setting an amount that was at the
far at the far end of what we knew was
feasible given our resources given our
time um but um like I just know our
personality for both of us and I think
this is why like we works okay so well
together sometimes is like we're both
incredibly ambitious and and we think
we're more human than we actually
connect some times where it's just like
like we try going for things that are
that are really really big and it's just
in both of our natures and you know I it
comes from I guess our background to
where like we're both the first in our
family to go to college you know like
like we have that spirit of pushing
through and pushing through and pushing
through all the time no matter what
against all odds sorry and I think you
know filmmaking is no different than
that we're like you just have to believe
you ever do it and you have to fail a
lot and get over it and get back up and
do it again like that's all you can do
and that's what we've always done our
entire life just you you go for it um so
it wouldn't be any different with this
i'm the same spirit
you